[Music]  he is Lindsay Arnold out on Dancing with  the Stars that felt like my whole leg  gave out the pro has had a stellar  season with partner Jordan Fisher they  just got two perfect scores and could be  headed for the mirror ball it would be  Lindsay's first but over the weekend  word surfaced the 23 year old had gotten  hurt  I was practicing the pro number and I  literally just stepped up onto a stair  and it felt like my whole leg gave out  and stopped working ET obtained this  clip Lindsay in tears it's frustrating  because it's the semifinals and I want  to dance it with Jordan and I just hope  this doesn't stop me from doing that we  spoke with Lindsay and Jordan just a few  days earlier and her words now seem  almost eerie it's the semifinals and at  this point like honestly I've seen a  happen time and time again any any  misstep any of the stake could seriously  cost them airballs tune into ABC Monday  night to see if Lindsay will dance  [Music]